the president used his overnight news
conference to fire back at his former
personal lawyer Michael Cohen mr. Trump
said Cohen's dramatic day long testimony
yesterday was in his words a fake
hearing having it in the middle of this
very important summit is really a
terrible thing he lied a lot but it was
very interesting because he didn't lie
about one thing he said no collusion
with the Russian hoax and I said I
wonder why he didn't just lie about that
- like you did about everything else
Cohen accused the president of lying and
breaking the law when the House
Oversight Committee hearing was over
the chairman said Cohen may have
incriminated the president Nancy Court
has covered it all on Capitol Hill Nancy
called it a fake hearing but a lot of
people watched and looked pretty real on
TV right and Cohen certainly painted a
pretty grim picture Gale of his former
boss describing him as a criminal
achieved a conman a liar and a racist he
did say that he had no direct evidence
of collusion with the Russians but he
will be back here on Capitol Hill today
testifying about the president's Russia
ties behind closed doors
I believe he told the truth House
Oversight Committee Chairman Elijah
Cummings presided over the nearly seven
hour hearing and said Michael Cohen left
them with plenty of leads to follow up
on based on what you've heard do you
believe that the president committed a
crime while in office based on what
looking at the text and listening to mr.
Cohen it appears that he did the
committee's top Republican disagreed
Michael Cohen can't be trusted Cohen was
emotional at times as he outlined his
role in various shady dealings over the
course of more than ten years I blindly
followed his demands my loyalty to mr.
Trump has cost me everything
this drew the most interest a check to
Cohen for $35,000 that President Trump
signed while in office reimbursement for
Cohen's $130,000 payout on mr. Trump's
behalf to keep porn star stormy Daniels
quiet
one says the check is direct evidence
the president conspired to violate
campaign finance laws the president was
aware of this scheme is that correct
that's correct
Cohen also accused his former boss of
tax fraud and intimidation
how many times did mr. Trump ask you to
threaten an individual or entity on his
behalf
quite a few times 50 times more a
hundred times more 500 times probably
over the over the ten years Republicans
noted Cohen is a convicted felon liar
liar pants on fire
Cohen admitted he lied in the past about
a Moscow real-estate deal he said that's
what the president wanted at the same
time I was actively negotiating in
Russia for him he would look me in the
eye and tell me there's no Russian
business and then go on to lie to the
American people by saying the same thing
and he insisted the president knew about
stolen Clinton campaign emails before
they were released by WikiLeaks is it
likely that Donald Trump was fully aware
and had every intent of working with
Russia to help make sure that he could
win the presidency at all costs mr.
Trump's desire to win would have him
work with anyone the Trump campaign is
slamming Cohen's testify saying in part
Michael Cohen is a felon a disbarred
lawyer and a convicted perjurer who lied
to both Congress and the special counsel
adding that his testimony has proven
before to be worthless Norah all right
Nancy thank you